- Welcome back everybody.
I'm here with Nick Jonas.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
So as I mentioned earlier,
Nick and his brothers are part
of an amazing popcorn line
called Rob's Backstage Popcorn.
It tastes so good.
And we have the original flavor here.
I heard y'all opening and touching it.
It was like everybody all the
sudden was like touching stuff
and I felt like it, it
was like an ASMR episode
or something.
(audience laughing)
- Open it up; open it up.
- I'm gonna take some too.
- Everyone in the audience has bags
so ya'll try it out and I'm sorry,
you're gonna get addicted to it.
So I have one here too; so.
- So, the thing about this
flavor, this is the original.
- This is sweet and salty.
- Sweet and salty.
- Mm hmm.
- It's is the perfect
combination of sweet and salty.
- It really is.
- The brothers and I are on
the back here with Rob himself
and what's cool about this
is that, you know, it's,
it tastes delicious and we
obviously love it 'cause,
you know, here we are.
But it also is, is, it's
in that better for you category; so.
- Gluten free.
- It's gluten free, vegan,
and it's, it's just delicious.
So.
- Yeah.
- And then the, the fun
part is now, we're, we're,
as you mentioned before, we're expanding.
- I know.
- Which is a very...
- You have a new flavor.
- We have a new flavor.
- Yeah.
- And we collaborated with
somebody really incredible on it.
- Just, aren't they?
They're just, they're
insanely cool, right?
This person.
- I'll give you a few guesses
to figure out who it is.
- Okay.
- They are a singer.
- May have been the, like,
the first ever American idol.
- Whoa.
(audience whooping)
- But, but besides that
has a really good palette
and understanding of taste.
- Distinguished palette.
- And a distinguished palette.
- Yes.
- And brought a lot of passion
to the creative process.
So I don't know if you guess-
- Exactly.
- who this, this person is, but.
- Well, it is me.
I love this popcorn so much,
(crowd cheers)
but I was super stoked.
He texted me about it one day
and I was like, hell yeah,
I wanna be part of it.
Hell yeah, I wanna do this.
Like, I love this popcorn so much,
but I was excited to make my own flavor.
Does anyone in the audience
wanna guess what my flavor is?
- Yes. Who wants to guess?
Yeah, I'm gonna go over here.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'm go over here.
- Okay.
- Hello!
- Hi.
- Hello. What's your name?
- I'm like, still eating it.
- My name's Kayeena.
- All right, we're gonna
try this, all right?
- Okay.
- Take a little bit there.
- All right.
- Tell me, I'm gonna try some.
- Okay.
(crowd groans)
- (Kelly and Nick laughing)
- Okay, okay.
- What do you think? What do you think?
- Ooh, ooh; is that Chipotle?
- No, mm.
- Ooh.
- I taste notes of tuna.
No, no.
- Tuna? (laughing)
- Stop.
- Olbay, olbay.
- Oh,oh.
No, stop being black; listen.
Uh...
(crowd laughing)
I think you would,
you would invite somebody-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- to this in your backyard.
- (giggling)
- You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- What do you think; you're
invited in to the backyard?
- To the backyard?
- Uh huh. With a smoker.
- Ooh, barbecue.
- That's what it is.
(crowd cheering)
- That's right, it's
Kelly's classic barbecue.
It is so good.
(crowd cheering)
I love that it makes you move.
- (laughing)
- It makes me move too.
It had to be spicy.
Everybody, this is it.
Kelly's classic barbecue.
(audience cheering)
- [Nick] There it is.
- [Kelly] All right, all right, all right.
It's so good.
- Thank you, Marcel.
Thank you Justin.
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh you guys.
- Look at this.
- You got to taste it.
You're so lucky.
- [man in suit] It's good.
- It is addictive.
- Mm.
- My friends kind of hate me
for it, but it's so good.
- So good.
- I know.
So you guys have a popcorn
social media contest
coming up for this, right?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- We have a very exciting con...
Sorry, I'm, I'm just
devouring this popcorn
- Because it's so good.
- So we're doing,
it's called the Rob's Falling
Popcorn Reels contest.
- Okay.
- Starts January 18th.
- Uh huh, okay.
- Which is Wednesday,
through the 24th.
- Okay.
- And basically the person that wins this
- Mm hm.
- is going to win a car,
which is amazing.
(crowd oohs and awes)
- You're like Oprah.
- A brand new car.
- You're like Oprah, I like this.
- And it's a very simple challenge.
So it's an AR Reels thing.
So basically, to try to catch
as many popcorn kernels as you can
in your mouth.
- Ooh, a game.
- In, you know, Reels.
And I think we should try to do it now,
- Oh.
- but with the real thing.
- Challenge accepted.
- Okay.
- Okay, so I wanna place
a bet on this, okay?
So if we can each catch five pieces
of popcorn in our mouths
- Mm hmm.
- in 15 seconds, which sounds easy.
I'm gonna feel like such
a loser if I don't do it.
Everyone in the audience
will win a hundred dollars
to get a stash of Rob's Backstage Popcorn.
(audience cheering)
- That's right.
Can we get 15 seconds on the clock,
and can we get some
popcorn catching music,
whatever that sounds like.
- (Nick chuckles)
- Okay, here we go.
And go.
(audience cheering)
(bell dings twice)
- One.
(bell dings)
- Two.
- Three.
(bell dings)
- Four.
(bell dings twice)
- Come on!
(bell dings)
(bell dings again)
(buzzer pulsing)
(crowd cheering)
(Kelly screams)
- Oh!
I think we did it.
Everybody wins a hundred dollars cash
for Rob's Backstage popcorn.
(crowd cheers)
- Let's bring out some Kelly's
classic barbecue popcorn
for the audience to enjoy
right now. (buzzer noises)
(audience cheers)
- You're welcome in advance people.
All right, Kelly's classic barbecue flavor
of Robs Backstage Popcorn
is available online
and a grocery store near you
nationwide starting tomorrow.
Trust me, you're gonna want some.